hot qui protège l'allemagne a pris
conscience et assument de plus en plus
ouvertement quelle est la puissance
centrale en europe le programme commun
qu'il s'apprête à mettre en oeuvre ne va
pas dans le sens des intérêts français
[Musique]
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions du procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde finalement
était formé de gens merveilleux aidé de
jean ignoble en fait vous ne savez pas
comment votre fils est mort vous devez
enquêter sur tout et vous confronter
les faits ni sur la liste des morts ni
sur la bbc initialiser hopitalisés et il
était nulle part est ce qu'on peut vivre
malgré cette douleur quand j'ai écrit à
la fois je souffrais parce que ça me
rappelait des beaux souvenirs avec
stéphane en même temps c'était très
douloureux et puis aujourd'hui je me
suis aperçu que ça permettait d'extraire
de de moi même toute cette histoire est
donc ça m'a apporté un peu de recul un
peu d'apaisement mais la douleur et la
colère seront là jusqu'à ma mort
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h30 pour décrypter les grands
titres de l'actualité de la journée au
sommaire de ce jeudi 16 décembre omicron
balle et l'espoir d'un noël tranquille
en france un nouveau conseil de défense
sanitaire se tiendra demain l'elysée de
nouvelles restrictions pourraient être
annoncées réactions la situation
sanitaire qui cessent de se dégrader en
france qui ne cesse de se dégrader en
france une progression à grand vitesse
du nouveau variant qui s'invite au
sommet divers des 27 l'union européenne
s'apprête à fixer à neuf mois la durée
du certificat vaccinales sont pas de
rappel décryptage dans quelques instants
avec la pandémie de kobe 19 la dette
publique mondiale a explosé l'an dernier
250 6 % du pib mondial une hausse record
de 28 % par rapport à 2010 9 la plus
forte depuis la seconde guerre mondiale
la france ne fait pas exception loin de
là sur le front du commerce extérieur
paris est aussi confronté un déficit qui
ne cesse de se creuser alors comment
expliquer cette situation la france est
elle encore dans le commerce mondial les
répondants l'édito échos de jacques
sapir
si on ira aux états unis où l'on se
replongera dans l'histoire de
l'assassinât du président john
fitzgerald kennedy des archives secrètes
vient d'être déclassifiées 58 ans après
la mort du 35e président américain la
sphère passionne toujours autant sa
disparition reste pour beaucoup un
militaire d'êta notre correspondance à
washington a consulté pour nous ces
documents du fbi et de la cia
président des riches hors sol un angle
la parole égocentré l'opposition à
gauche comme à droite ne mâche pas ses
mots au lendemain de l'interview
d'emmanuel mais crombez réformes
économiques au kobe 19 ans passe enfin
les gilet jaune au président a
longuement défendu hier son bilan un
exercice qui n'aurait ni convaincu ni
mobiliser les français selon un tout
dernier sondage to show réalisé ce soir
pour le figaro alors l'interview
d'emmanuel macron at-elle fait un flop
on attend vos avis sur le conte
télégramme daté france
la france pourrait prendre de nouvelles
mesures anti qu'ovide l approche des
fêtes un conseil de défense sanitaire
est donc prévue demain face à
l'augmentation des cas et la pression
hospitalière on retrouve notre reporter
emilie goog h devant le ministère de la
santé bonsoir et midi alors doit-on
s'attendre un nouveau tour de vis pour
les fêtes de noël
bonsoir c'est fanny oui en tout cas si
on se base sur les derniers chiffres
publiés par santé publique france plus
de 65000 nouvelles contaminations mais
aussi plus de quinze mille patients
qu'ovide hospitalisés tous les
indicateurs semblent au rouge d'autant
plus avec le variant omicron qui
poursuit sa propagation alors sur quoi
va porter ce conseil de défense
sanitaire demain bien que rien ne soit
décidée pour le moment on peut
s'attendre à ce qu'il n'y ait pas de
mesures exceptionnelles à savoir pas de
re confinement pas de couvre-feu ou
d'interdiction de se déplacer en
revanche d'après le porte parole du
gouvernement
gabriel attal l'exécutif va plutôt se
tourner vers l'accélération de la
campagne vaccinale également sur l'
annonce de recommandation à l' approche
des fêtes de fin d'année et le
renforcement des contrôles aux
frontières qui lui a déjà été annoncé et
millier déjà une restriction celle donc
vous l'aviez aux frontières la france
qui a décidé donc de durcir les
contrôles avec le royaume uni
et oui c'est un durcissement qui a été
annoncé par gabriela talent ce jeudi
matin le premier ministre britannique
avait lui-même parlé d'un raz-de-marée
d'eau mikron c'était il y a quelques
jours et bien en france cela justifie
que les voyageurs britanniques soient
strictement contrôlée dès ce samedi que
ce soit pour les textes antiques au vide
ou encore pour les motifs de déplacement
je vous propose d'écouter et à gabriella
tél à ce sujet on va de réduire la durée
de validité du test pour venir en france
c'était 48 heures jusqu'à maintenant ça
va passer à 24 heures ça veut dire qu'on
va limiter les motifs qui permettent de
venir du royaume uni en france ça va
être limitée aux nationaux résidents
français et à leurs familles et donc
tout ce qui est tourisme ou déplacements
professionnels pour des personnes qui
n'ont pas la nationalité française ou
européenne qui ne sont pas résidentes en
france évidemment ce sera limité
le porte parole du gouvernement
également annoncé li seulement pour sept
jours des personnes qui arrivent en
france isolement qui sera contrôlée mais
qui pourra être levé une fois qu'un test
covin négatif négatif sera confirmée 6
ml le variant omicron qui pourrait donc
devenir d'un taux dominant sur le vieux
continent d'ailleurs cette nouvelle
souche s'invite au sommet de l'hiver des
vingt-sept
absolument bruxelles a réaffirmé son
souhait d'une approche coordonnée pour
éviter notamment toute entrave
disproportionnée à la liberté de
circulation car pour l'instant les 27 à
agissent un peu en ordre dispersé sans
réelle cohésion pour ce qui est des
voyages par exemple on l'a vu avec le
cas france royaume uni mais il ya aussi
le même cas de figure pour l'irlande le
portugal l'italie ou la grèce qui impose
ce voyageur même lorsqu'ils sont
vaccinés de présenter un test négatif
pour pouvoir entrer sur leur territoire
les 27 ont également souligné l'urgence
d'accélérer la vaccination contre le coc
vide 19 les dirigeants européens jugent
cruciale l'extension de la vaccination à
tous mais aussi l'administration de la
fameuse troisième dose bruxelles qui
veut fixer la durée du certificat
vaccinale à neuf mois après une première
vaccination complète afin donc
d'encourager ces rappels merci mille
îles google en direct donc devant le
ministère de la santé l'hôpital français
et souffre évidemment de cette 5ème
vannes le nombre de patients atteints du
coc vide dans les services de soins
critiques devraient atteindre les 4000
autour des fêtes alertes lancées donc
hier par gabriela attal mais mes
questions la france dispose t-elle de
suffisamment de lits de réanimation
éléments de réponse tout de suite avec
liam un rossi cela faisait un moment que
ce document était attendu par les
professionnels du secteur de la santé un
rapport commandé à l'igas en février par
le gouvernement pour évaluer les
capacités de soins intensifs en france
sous pression à chaque nouvelle vague de
l'épidémie de copines alors pas
d'alarmisme de la part de l'igas selon
le quotidien le monde qui s'est procuré
le rapport met des recommandations
prudentes notamment sur le nombre de
lits l'accroissement prévisible des
besoins de réanimation liée
principalement au vieillissement
démographique n'appelle pas
d'augmentation massive du nombre de lits
installés sur la base d'une estimation
maximaliste cet accroissement des
besoins pourrait rendre nécessaire la
création de 1000 lits de réanimation
supplémentaires d'ici à 2030 plus 1000
lits d'ici la fin de la décennie pour ce
faire les gaz préconise deux leviers
d'action premièrement la création de
services de rééducation post réanimation
ce qui permettrait d'économiser des lidd
réa et deuxièmement la réouverture des
lits actuellement fermées par manque de
personnel ce qui signifie donc
l'embauchent de soignants la ligue as
rejoint le constat fait est bien par à
peu près tout le monde l'hôpital manque
de bras 10% des 5000 80 lits de
réanimation que compte le pays sont
actuellement fermés peut-on lire dans le
rapport un chiffre qui monte à 15 % en
ile-de-france selon les agences
régionales de santé selon l'igas il
manquerait en tout 1135 médecin un
chiffre qui fait écho à ceux de la cour
des comptes qui tirait déjà la sonnette
d'alarmé en mars dernier la crise
sanitaire est intervenue dans un
contexte de fragilité structurelle des
ressources humaines et n'a pas conduit
les autorités à modifier sans si ble
ment ses effectifs le taux d'équipement
en lits de réanimation n'était plus que
de 37 pour cent mille habitants de plus
de 65 ans à la veille de la crise
sanitaire contre 44 en 2013 en
conservant son ratio de 2013 la france
aurait disposé de 5949 lits de
réanimation contre 5080 au 1er janvier
2020 soit près de 900 lits de
réanimation n'ont créé on est tout
proche d'emilie manquants selon l'igas
et qui auraient été bien utiles au plus
fort de l'épidémie tout comme les plus
de cent mille lits d'hospitalisation
fermé en 25 ans d'ailleurs entre 1993 et
2000 18 des coupes notamment dû au
virage de l'ambulatoire opéré par
l'hôpital français et qui se sont
poursuivis pendant le coït du reste
puisque près de six mille lits
supplémentaires ont été supprimés en
2020 bref l'hôpital est anémiée et cela
ne date pas d'hier si personne ne
pouvait prévoir la crise du coc vide la
fragilité de notre système de soins
résulte bien elle de choix politiques
services hospitaliers sous tension taux
d'incidence qui explose en france et
partout en europe conseil de défense
sanitaire demain la crise du comique qui
s'invite au menu du conseil de l'europe
des 27 il faut dire que le avancent en
ordre dispersé depuis le début de cette
pandémie ait du mal à unifier sa
politique sanitaire place à notre
décryptage
[Musique]
avec nous pour en parler philippe
froguel chercheur et généticiens bonsoir
philippe froguel merci d'être avec nous
pierre schott ailier infirmier à
l'hôpital beaujon membres du collectif
intérieur gens sur ce plateau ici merci
à vous d'être là et enfin depuis
barcelone en espagne philippe emmanueli
médecin donc libéral français sur place
pour voir un petit peu comment ça se
passe de votre côté philippe emmanueli
merci d'être avec nous alors aux
microbes qui fait peur au point de
bouleverser évidemment l'agenda des 27
philippe froguel je me souviens que
quand j'aurai reçu il ya de cela trois
semaines vous m'aviez dit si ce virus
est très contagieux et peu dangereux ce
pourrait être une bonne nouvelle car
c'est comme cela que les épidémies meurt
alors est-ce que vous avez des bonnes
nouvelles enfin nous annoncer ce soir
parce que manifestement pas très
dangereux mais très contagieuse c'est
tôt mikron
alors effectivement omicron semblerait
un peu moins dangereux que le delta mais
comme il est extrêmement contagieux et
va toucher beaucoup beaucoup de monde et
on fait la loterie des réponses de
individuelle va faire quand même qu'on
risque d'avoir plus de personnes
hospitalisées tout simplement parce
qu'on a une explosion du nombre de
nouveaux cas et on a un deuxième
problème que on n'avait pas anticipé
c'est que et notamment un système
français où il ya très peu de tout est
mais il ya beaucoup de gens qui se sont
contaminées qui font des formes très
légère voire asymptomatiques qui ne se
teste pas mais qui peuvent transmettre à
quelqu'un qui lui va où elle va faire
une forme formes graves et donc
effectivement on est haut aujourd'hui au
début de la sixième vague qui hélas se
superpose à la cinquième avec tous les
dangers qu'il ya pour notre système de
santé
nous entende et philippe froguel et puis
voilà vous voyez cette micro nous
arriver droit devancé j'ose dire ça vous
inquiète vous
alors que la pression hospitalière est
déjà très forte
c'est de plus en plus inquiétant c'est à
dire c'est qu'on va arriver à un stade
où en réalité c'est plus la pandémie qui
va mettre en danger l'hôpital c'est
l'hôpital qui sera plus en capacité du
tout prendre en charge la pandémie qui
influera sur la prise en charge de la
pandémie mais si elle est moins
dangereuse pour la population on a de
moins en moins de ligue 1 les lions vont
continuer à fermer pendant la pandémie
comme on a pu le voir la politique de
destruction l'hôpital public se poursuit
et malheureusement à côté de ça même si
le variant est moins dangereux à chaque
fois qu'on aura une espèce
hôpitalisation mais là on parle du duc
au but mais ça pourrait très bien être
la graine dans les prochaines années on
ne sera pure mesure de prendre en charge
ces patients là on sera débordé à la
moindre petite petite vague aujourd'hui
vous en voyez déjà les premières
on a une très clairement on a une
augmentation des consultations et des
hospitalisations pour
locaux vides philippe emmanuel dit quand
vous entendez en france
on se demande quelle est la situation en
espagne parce qu'on relève on en parlera
d'ailleurs avec philippe rogué devant
quelques instants on relève 240 cas
officielle en france quelle est la
situation en espagne aujourd'hui
oui bien ici on est pas une le variant
au micro et non pas gâcher les fêtes de
noël et on voit ici également les cas se
sont multipliés
c'est vrai que le conseil scientifique
belle à des mesures restrictives plus
importante mais pour le moment le
gouvernement reste dans la tente des
prochains jours pour prendre
éventuellement de nouvelles décisions
alors philippe froguel on le disait 240
cas officiel ça c'est gabriel attal le
porte parole du gouvernement qui nous en
parler un chiffre est il le dit
d'ailleurs lui-même de son propre aveu
certainement sous-estimé vous le le
champion le spécialiste du séquençage
évidemment j'imagine que nous abondons
vous abondé dans ce sens sous-estimer ce
nombre oui il n'ya pas 240 cas y en a
probablement plusieurs milliers par jour
en fait vu le temps qu'il faut en france
et à peu près 15 jours pour voir les
résultats on aide un et 244 et peut-être
réel ya deux semaines ne sont absolument
pas aujourd'hui moi j'estime
probablement à plusieurs milliers de
3000 au moins qu'à de micron par jour en
france en partout en france un
particulièrement bon moment à paris et
ce qui se passe en angleterre c'est à
dire plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
micro probablement 150000 c'est ce que
disent les autorités et moi je sais pas
ce que j'aime et j'ai ma famille en
angleterre et mes fils me disait tout
leurs amis sont atteints et bien prévoit
un million de cas par jour à la fin du
elle à la fin du mois c'est ce qui va
nous arriver donc qu'il va y avoir une
famille qui va nous arriver dessus et il
faut que l'hôpital tiennent le cndp est
simple ça va pas être simple clairement
philippe h par tellier on imagine que
vous en parlez entre vous
c'est invariant qui n'est pas comme les
autres pour vous encore plus contagieux
et donc plus inquiétant après deux ans
déjà de grandes fatigues dans tous les
services je vous avouerai qu'on n'a pas
de vision jusqu'au vergne en comics on
voit le jour genre après le jour et la
situation et les deux prisons plus
dramatique je vous dis c'est qu'on a de
moins en moins de livres on arrive de
moins en moins à prendre déjà de base et
les patients ce cas là on est en train
de de t'arrêter des opérations de
limiter l'accès aux opérations de de
repousser toutes les skis peut être
repousser et malheureusement ces
patients là c'est des patients qui vont
arriver dans un état encore plus grave
qu'avant et aujourd'hui on augmente le
nom de l'urgence et l'hôpital
aujourd'hui ne fait que quasiment de
l'urgence de la prise en charge des
urgences et
ccc destructeur pour le pour les
patients mais c'est destructeur pour les
soignants quand vous entendez emmanuel
macron hier dire que le problème n'est
pas un manque de lits parce que rien
compris je pense que malheureusement il
n'a rien compris et ça fait depuis 2000
19 que les soignants se bat pour
dénoncer cette casse en tout cas ces
fermetures de lits et ça fait partie de
nos premières revendications depuis 2006
9 avec le collectif interrogé
expliquez-nous concrètement comment ça
se passe pour bien qu'on comprenne parce
que ça veut dire clairement que
quelqu'un qui a un accident de la route
soit
évidemment pu prendre en charge parce
que les services d'urgence saturé alors
pour pour les accidents de la route pour
les autres la gestion des urgences on
arrivera toujours à faire avec beaucoup
de retard on peut voir qu'il ya eu un
seul l'udc a attendu plus de trois
heures par une place dans l'animation il
ya encore des pompiers qui ont attendu
7h30 pour être pris en charge enfin on
va prendre en charge le problème je
prends l'exemple par exemple des avc
là où avant un avc on allait pouvoir
récupérer la personne n'allait peut-être
pas avoir de handicap aujourd'hui
quasiment toutes les patients qui sont
un avc sont récupérées trop tard et ont
des handicaps ça va coûter de plus en
plus cher à la sécurité sociale et ça va
faire des patients qu'ils donnent toutes
manières d'y perdre leur autonomie donc
on va créer toute une génération de
patients qu'on va sauver ils vont pas
mourir mais ils vont avoir des
conséquences de cette pathologie qui
jusqu'à présent on arrivait à limiter
ses conséquences aujourd'hui on ne peut
plus limités et le cas de la neuro
vasculaire sur l'île de france en
particulier et il est symptomatique
c'est dramatique c'est en train de se
passer on a 30 % des lits qui sont
fermées de neuro vasculaire essaie des
choses ou dans l'hôpital où on a une
phrase c'est le temps c'est du cerveau
plus on ira plus on sauve du cerveau
l'actuel mandat on n'arrive plus à
sauver tout le cerveau est aujourd'hui
il ya des conséquences graves qui se
paye sur les soignants sur le sort des
patients par mois mais ça ne se voit pas
en terme de mortalité signal mais les
conséquences elles sont elles sont très
lourdes et elles vont être on va les
porter jusqu'à la fin enfin m on peut
plus rattraper ce retard qu'on a pris
c'est trop tard pour santé aux patients
alors mikron un qui va devenir
majoritaires en europe d'ici la mi
janvier tel point que ce sujet s'est
invitée aujourd'hui au conseil européen
diverses et l'un des objets de ce
décryptage l'europe qui essayent tant
bien que mal de trouver des solutions
communes philippe froguel justement vous
qui êtes entre la france et le royaume
uni on imagine que vous souffrez des
premières restrictions qui se sont
tendues entre les deux frontières
notamment c'est une bonne chose quand
même pour le généticien vous êtes
c'était une décision nécessaire et qui
arrive peut-être même trop tard
sa part du principe qu en france la
situation est bien meilleure qu'en
angleterre ce qui est loin d'être sûr
puisque en angleterre on fait un
dépistage par pcr suivi de séquençage de
tous les câbles douteux qui pourrait
être microns alors qu'en france ce qui
est fait est minimale donc le
gouvernement français fait comme si en
angleterre c'était la tragédie par un
micro et qu'en france on est on était
encore en train de s'en protéger je
pense que on est simplement à 10 jours
qu'un jour derrière les anglais et que
ça va venir de toute façon donc les
mesures qui sont prises c'est plutôt de
la communication plutôt que de la
réalité et c'est en train d'exploser
partout en france donc mais je répète
que
en angleterre à londres en particulier
c'est l'hécatombe ça veut pas dire que
les gens m'a énormément mais
beaucoup de gens sont atteints y compris
les jeunes car au micro on touche
beaucoup les jeunes ça c'était quelque
chose qui a bien été reconnue en afrique
du sud quand vous dites ça touche à
beaucoup les jeunes ça les touche dans
quelles proportions ça veut dire on
avait évoqué tout à l'heure une forme
d'un traumatisme
beaucoup de gens apparemment font des
formes mineures il ya selon ce qui est
dit il faudra vérifier des enfants en
bas âge non vaccinés font des formes
parfois graves et mortels mais il faut
les hospitalisés et surtout les gens
sont très très très très contagieux les
ici touche à des gens âgés il ya un
risque important que ces gens se
retrouvent à l'hôpital où effectivement
y'a pas il ya très très peu de lits les
premières ce qui était dit à côté moi
tissu diabétologue je peux vous dire que
dès maintenant en ce moment les
diabétiques qui arrivent à l'hôpital
sont plus graves qu'il ya deux ans parce
que avec eaux-vives et le manque de
capacité qu'on a eu à les soigner
pendant deux ans et bien un an et demi
eh bien ils ont ils ont des
complications du diabète est la même
chose pour les avc et autres situations
cacher
ses pairs qu'il n'est pas lié
directement au vide et dramatique on en
paiera les conséquences pendant dix ans
finit par emmanuel et en espagne
justement sur ce que viennent de décrire
nos invités à notamment monsieur je fais
obteniez sur ce plateau la situation d
hôpital à se caler un petit peu
meilleure parce qu'on sait qu'on n'a pas
la même politique chez vous un il n'y a
pas de passes annie terre par exemple
sauf en catalogne où vous êtes
population majoritairement vacciner
sommes en france troisième dose qui
s'est ouverte aujourd'hui au plus de 40
ans il semble y avoir de plutôt bons
résultats vous vous sentez à l'abri de
cette situation
finalement ça va être la même chose dans
quelques semaines également votre
sentiment
c'est très difficile à dire ce qu'on
peut dire c'est que le système de santé
espagnol est radicalement différent du
sist de santé français il a beaucoup
souffert lors de la première vague et il
a été débordé de façon beaucoup plus
importante qu'en france lors de la
première vague mais ensuite il a su
mettre en place
effectivement une organisation
extrêmement réactif dédié à l'épidémie
est aujourd'hui effectivement
n'entendent pas ce débat sur
l'insuffisance du système de santé en
espagne faut quand même rappeler c'est
paradoxal mais en espagne la santé
représente deux points de moins que le
pib en france et l'espérance de vie y
est supérieur
donc différence finalement de politique
c'est quoi la politique du gouvernement
la manière d'approcher et d'aborder
cette épidémie selon vous pierre
chevalier je sais pas si l'exemple de la
part de pib est un bon exemple parce que
le pays qui donne le plus de parts de
pib dans sa santé c'est les états unis
avec 16% du pib là où nous on est à onze
pour cent je suis pas sûr que les états
unis sous l eldorado de la santé je
pense que là pour le coup il faut plus
regarder le pib par habitant est en
l'occurrence la france est 12e et
l'espagne je crois doit être 13e à très
loin derrière mais on est sensiblement
égalité en termes de pib par habitant
après ben oui effectivement on subit une
politique en france de destruction
l'hôpital public qui date depuis plus de
dix ans mais voilà où on est on paye les
conséquences de cette politique de cette
casse de l'hôpital public aujourd'hui la
seule solution qu'on nous propose c'est
d'attendre d'eux les prochaines sorties
des écoles d'attendre on augmente les
places en en institut de formation
notamment on sera fermée mais ça ça
devient ridicule puisque un fermier ces
trois ans d'études et la moyenne de
l'espérance de vie de cette profession
ces quatre ans vous aimeriez qu'on
unifie justement les règles en europe
parce que ça j'ai aujourd'hui aussi de
ce débat où de toute manière c'est un
combat perdu d'avancé tant comme nous
l'a dit d'ailleurs philippe et magnoni
ne serait-ce contre l'espagne et la
france ce sont des systèmes totalement
différent et je ne parle pas des les 25
autres on a tous des systèmes de santé
assez différent mais je pense que en
tout cas ce qui aurait dû être fait dès
le début c'était la levée des brevets
sur les vaccins aujourd'hui 80% de la
population mondiale qui n'a pas accès au
vaccin si on a des mutations de vaccins
c'est dans ces pays ou qui n'ont pas du
tout été vaccinés et où on va avoir les
nerfs jans effectivement futur de
possible future variante qui pour le
coup pour être résistant aux vaccins et
s'attaquer aux plus jeunes donc là on a
le variant micron c'est un peu ce qu'on
redoutait depuis maintenant un nom on
essaye de se battre pour la levée des
progrès sur les vaccins on espère qu'il
résiste quand même aux vaccins et qu'il
ne dessine pas la population des plus
jeunes en tout cas mais voilà c'est
l'urgence aujourd'hui c'est bien
évidemment que que les vaccins soient
accessibles au plus grand nombre alors
une première réaction télégramme elle
nous vient de philippe deux dos trois
doses cadoz à quoi servent les vaccins
justement est-ce que l'épidémie repart
très fortement à la hausse en europe
vous venez appelez de vos voeux la levée
de des brevets des vaccins en tout cas
c'est déjà presque trop tard pour vous
philippe froguel justement pour répondre
à votre homonyme philippe à quoi ça sert
parce que je crois que c'est un hasard
donc à communiquer 70 % d'efficacité il
me semble à la deuxième dose
c'est vrai que au micron va plus vite
que les variations du vaccin si j'ose
dire
oui mais pas si on reçoit la dose de
rappel la troisième dose on augmente
très fortement ces anticorps et on
arrive à quand même à 70 80 % à bloquer
au micro c'est en tout cas c'est ce que
c'est ce qu'on dit
sont les études quelques études qui ont
été faites aujourd'hui et c'est à peu
près la seule chose qu'on peut faire
c'est à dire de ce qu'on n'a pas de
maxime deuxième génération la seule
chose qu'on peut faire aujourd'hui c'est
d'avoir une troisième dose pour noyer au
micron dans un déluge d'anticorps s'est
il paraît que ça marche j'espère que
c'est vrai et c'est à peu près tout ce
qu'on peut faire aujourd'hui avec les
gestes barrières bien entendu quel que
soit philippe robert ça c'est une
question pratique que j'en profite pour
vous poser mais c'est vrai beaucoup de
centres de vaccination aujourd'hui
proposent par exemple du moderna puisque
du finder qui est très plébiscité près
la communication de ce laboratoire ça
veut dire que si on s'est fait vacciner
ou father et qu'on se fait vacciner par
exemple au moderna derrière c'est tout
aussi efficace
oui aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de grosse
différence d'autres le fassent the run
moderna
l12 initiale de modern a été deux fois
plus importante que le kaiser et ça
entraînait parfois j'ai des jeunes et
mieux car beat là maintenant ils ont
baissé et je pense que c'est à peu près
équivalent c'est très très proche d'un
des ce qu'ont fait les deux laboratoires
et donc je pense que caen face rien ou
l'autre ça change pas grand chose
dernière question on parlait de l'europe
et de ce conseil européen
il ya une annonce à l'europe qui
s'apprête à fixer à 9 après une première
vaccination complète la durée de
validité du certificat vaccinale contre
le coc vide donc pour les voyages intra
européen afin d'encourager les les
rappels c'est une bonne chose pour le
médecin que vous êtes une bonne décision
commune pour une fois européenne
mettez tout toute décision commune
l'europe est bienvenu car elle clarifie
effectivement la situation pour
l'ensemble des citoyens
en fait au-delà de ce nouvel épisode qui
ce nouveau variant la situation a quand
même largement évolué puisque
aujourd'hui on a des vaccins aujourd'hui
on a des traitements aujourd'hui on a
des sérums avec des anticorps donc c'est
vrai qu' on est aujourd'hui de toute
façon condamné à avancer ensemble
deux ans cette épidémie
effectivement merci en tout cas philippe
froguel pierre favier sur ce plateau et
philippe emmanuelli merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec monde nous avoir
apporté votre décryptage ce soir
la lutte anti copie de en allemagne en
cet après midi le ministre de la santé a
appelé à accélérer la campagne de
vaccination pour contrer omicron berlin
qui a promis de mener une lutte
implacable contre les anti vaccins
plusieurs élus des journalistes et des
institutions reçu des lettres de menace
en raison du projet de vaccination
obligatoire les précisions à berlin de
peter oliver d'arte et internationales
lui les causes delights s'était muni qui
est la dernière ville allemande en date
avoir une manifestation d'anti vax ainsi
que de gens opposés aux restrictions
d'entrée en vigueur afin d'essayer
d'endiguer locaux vides
d'après la police 4000 personnes
manifester en bavière de manière plutôt
calme jusqu'à ce qu'un groupe de quatre
à cinq cents personnes entament une
marche autour de la ville
s'en est suivi un jeu du chat et de la
souris avec la police quelques heures et
il fit n'est d'après la police 38
arrestations pour des motifs allant du
refus de port du masque à l'agression
d'officiers de police on constate que
ces manifestations dégénèrent de plus en
plus rapidement et que de plus en plus
de personnes prennent part à des
violences
ils sont extrêmement dangereux parce
qu'ils ne font pas que parler discuter
et se persuader les uns les autres ils
passent aussi à l'acte
ces manifestations rassemblent des anti
vaccins et des opposants aux
restrictions mais ils sont en majorité
regroupés sous le nom de penseurs
latéraux ils sont largement tourné en
dérision en allemagne dans les
programmes de télévision satirique et
ailleurs mais la situation a pris un
tournant bien plus sombre
ce mercredi matin il y a eu des
perquisitions dans l'état de la saxe
dans l'est de l'allemagne en lien avec
un complot visant à assassiner
selon les informations communiquées par
la police le chef du gouvernement de la
région de la saxe michael kretschmer et
ciblons également d'autres figures
politiques de la région
la saxe allende et où les plus bas de
vaccination de l'allemagne est l'un des
taux les plus élevés de contamination
suite à ces opérations
cinq hommes et une femme ont été placés
en détention
de nombreux politiques ont condamné
l'application de messagerie télégramme
en disant que c'est sur ce type de
plateformes que de tels plans peuvent
s'organiser et que le message peut se
répandre
c'est une des conséquences de la crise
sanitaire la dette mondiale a atteint un
niveau record l'an passé une hausse de
28% par rapport à 2019 la plus forte
depuis la seconde guerre mondiale ce
montant qui s'est envolé représente 250
6 % du pib mondial c'est la conclusion
d'un rapport publié par le fonds
monétaire international
[Musique]
bon
et on vient de voir donc la dette
mondiale qui a atteint un niveau record
en 2020 avec cette crise sanitaire en
france emmanuel macron sont tout aussi
inquiet le président a appelé hier à la
vigilance sur la situation de la dette
publique dans le pays pas un mot en
revanche sur notre commerce extérieur un
sujet d'ailleurs très peu évoquée à
quatre mois de la présidentielle alors
comment expliquer ce déficit qui se
creuse la france est elle encore dans le
commerce mondial la stout 8 à l'édito
échos de jacques sapir le centième du
genre
[Musique]
bonsoir ac félicitations donc à on est
heureux de vous accueillir pour ce
centième numéro de votre édito et bercy
vous stéfanie lasnier pas voilà on est
là toujours là malgré le coc vide on se
penche donc sur un sujet restait jusqu'à
présent dans l'ombre de la campagne
présidentielle c'est le déficit
commercial de la france tout d'abord
avoir un commerce extérieur déficitaire
c'est grave docteur pour passer dans le
sujet en fait ça dépend ça dépend il ya
des pays qui ont des déficits
conjoncturels certaines années parfois
c'est même provoqué par un choc
extérieur ce qui est effectivement
inquiétant dans le cas de la france
c'est que nous avons un déficit
maintenant pratiquement continu depuis
2003 donc ça va faire dix huit ans donc
ça c'est déjà un problème qui est
extrêmement important et qui démontre en
fait un problème de compétitivité
générale de l'économie française or il
faut savoir que le travailleur français
est l'un des plus productifs du monde il
est par exemple plus productif que son
confrère allemand donc le fait que l'on
est à la fois cette perte de
compétitivité et pourtant ce niveau de
productivité très haut ça pose un
véritable problème et on va voir que en
fait il ya des raisons mais l'une des
raisons ça pourrait être bien être
l'introduction de l'euro en 2002 alors
je connais tout d'abord qu'en est-il un
premier à poser le problème exactement
de ce déficit commercial de la france
alors le déficit commercial de la france
en fait ils commencent on avait eu déjà
des années avec un déficit mais il
commence vraiment à devenir systématique
et là on le voit à partir
2003 chose aussi qui était extrêmement
importante c'est que c'est autour de la
crise de 2008 que ce déficit prend
vraiment c'est cette dimension tout à
fait historique
on est entre 2 et 3% du déficit ensuite
chose qui est aussi extrêmement
intéressante et mais aussi très
inquiétante c'est que en 2020 l'année
dernière alors que pourtant l'économie
elles avaient reculé de 8% à cause de la
crise sanitaire bien et bien c'est là
ont fait l'un des pires chiffres du
déficit commercial moins 65 milliards
d'euros alors même que l'on est très en
deçà de notre pib autrement dit nous
avons fait à cette époque la fin l'année
dernière plus de 3% du déficit donc oui
il ya bien un problème extrêmement
sérieux et comment expliquer alors il ya
plusieurs explications qui sont
possibles il ya d'abord le fait que très
clairement les importations croire
beaucoup plus vite que nos exportations
et ça on le voit à partir de la fin des
années 90 du début des années 2000 le
rythme de croissance des importations
est beaucoup plus rapide que celui des
exportations ça c'est un premier point
après on peut se demander est-ce que
c'est pas par exemple la cause de la
facture énergétique par le prix du
pétrole le prix du gaz sauf que les
années où le prix du pétrole et du gaz a
été particulièrement faible 2014 et 2015
même chose par exemple en 2020 on aurait
dû s'attendre à voir notre déficit
diminué eh bien pas du tout donc ça veut
dire qu'il y a un autre problème est ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que si on
désagrège le déficit après par pays et
bien les deux pays
par rapport auquel nous avons le déficit
le plus important c'est la chine et
l'allemagne à eux deux ils représentent
47 milliards sur grosso modo 65 donc
saviez qu'il représente a vraiment un
montant extrêmement important par contre
le pays sur lequel nous avons notre
excédent le plus important passé la
grande bretagne dommage qu'il soit
qu'ils aient quitté
l'union européenne mais qu'est ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire que le déficit
commercial de la france il est
essentiellement due aux biens
manufacturés et ça c'est vraiment la
trace de la désindustrialisation une
désindustrialisation qui se poursuit en
france depuis grosso modo les années 90
début 2000 et qui ne s'est jamais arrêté
est-ce qu'on n'a pas des points
d'excellence tout de même si bien sûr
bien sûr nous avons l'aéronautique nous
avons les industries du luxe nous avons
aussi l'agriculture
mais il faut savoir que une balance
commerciale quand on l'a désagrège ans
j'irai en grand blog il y allait bien il
ya les services alors traditionnellement
et on le voit sur ce graphique là la
balance des services elle a toujours été
excédentaire ce n'est pas un hasard
c'est par exemple le poids du tourisme
en france on a eu orco vise évidemment
on avait eu pratiquement 100 millions de
touristes par an bon ce qui est
important c'est que depuis 2010 à peu
près et bien
l'importance de ce flux qui vient de la
balance des services n'arrive plus du
tout à compenser le déficit de la
balance des biens et donc ça veut bien
dire que c'est essentiellement sur les
biens manufacturés que se trouve
aujourd'hui le problème alors pourtant
jette les autres pays de l'union
européenne et ceux des industriels
c'est pas facile à berlin où les
industriels disent également à des
degrés divers oui c'est vrai mais ce que
l'on constate aussi c'est que le rythme
de cette désindustrialisation et bien il
n'est pas du tout le même en france de
ce qu'il est en allemagne ou de ce qu'il
est en italie prenons par exemple le cas
de l'allemagne de l'allemagne elle a eu
effectivement elle aussi un déficit de
la balance commerciale dans les années
1995 2000 qui était en partie d'ailleurs
liées à la réunification allemande et
puis après et on le voit là aussi sur le
graphique c'est la gueule l'allemagne et
la courbe jaune est bien l'excédent
commercial explose il atteint entre 7 et
8% du pib alors que dans le même temps
et bien effectivement
le déficit commercial de la france
s'aggrave
donc comme je l'aï déjà dit nous entrons
en déficit à partir de 2003 et on voit
bien qu'il y a là un véritable problème
parce que l'allemagne est notre premier
partenaire faut jamais l'oublier et
comme nous sommes d'ailleurs le premier
partenaire de l'allemagne aussi un nous
sommes très liés de ce point de vue là
et donc on voit bien qu'il y a un énorme
problème en termes de
désindustrialisation
alors quelle est la cause de ce tournant
du début des années 2000 que vous nous
décrivez bon il ya de nombreuses causes
mais il ya une cause que l'on peut
maintenant vraiment isolé c'est la
question de l'euro vous savez que l'euro
bassa
introduisent une certaine manière des
parités de change fixe entre les
différentes monnaies puisque nous avons
introduit l'euro en 1999 pour l'ensemble
des calculs financiers en 2002 pour les
billets mais qu'est ce que ça veut dire
ça veut dire que tout ce qui était
produit en france étaient transférés en
euros au fameux taux de 6 francs 56 pour
un euro dans le même temps les
inflations dans les différents pays
membres de la zone euro n'ont pas
convergé elles sont restées assez
largement divergentes ce qui veut dire
qu'on commençait à apparaître des effets
de sous-évaluation et de surévaluation
de l'économie qui sont extrêmement
importants alors la france on le voit là
elle est surévalué d'environ 11% après
envoya l'italie l'espagne à d'autres
pays qui sont aussi surévaluée mais
l'allemagne et je reviens à ce que j'ai
dit tout à l'heure l'allemagne notre
premier client qui est aussi notre
premier fournisseur et bien elle elle
est sous-évalué 2 15% autrement dit il y
a un écart de 26 % et 26 %
c'est vraiment tout à fait énorme en
termes de commerce international entre
l'économie française et l'économie
allemande par ailleurs ça montre aussi
que l'économie française est bien
surévalué par rapport au reste du monde
puisque pour être non surévaluent il
faudrait qu'on soit au niveau zéro dans
la zone euro est bien là aussi alors ça
peut-être moins d'impact mais ça permet
de comprendre aussi pourquoi
eh bien la france accumule un tel
déficit commercial par par rapport à la
chine par exemple donc on voyait que la
question de l'euro est tout à fait
central alors vous nous parler de cette
catastrophe un dual euros est ce que ce
constat est partagé par la classe
politique n'a pas vraiment pas vraiment
regardé on a eu la semaine dernière le
fameux débat entre eric zemmour et bruno
le maire alors l'un et l'autre ont
reconnu que la question du déficit
commercial était un problème bon mais
n'ont jamais évoqué l'euro c'est vous
pouvez réécouter la vidéo jamais le
monde euro n'a été prononcée alors c'est
quand même tout à fait étonnant on a
deux personnes et en particulier le
ministre de l'économie des finances
quand même qui connaît bien les dossiers
qui
décrivent une situation mais qui sont
incapables d'expliquer d'où vient cette
situation et ça si vous voulez je crois
et je crains que ce soit bien le produit
de l'immense hypocrisie que l'on a sur
la question de l'euro dans la classe
politique française merci beaucoup
jacquet pour ce décryptage et à dans
deux semaines en pour les jours écho
puisque nous sommes en vacances la
semaine prochaine même si à vous et
bonne 100e encore merci beaucoup
les politiques au royaume uni à présent
avec une législative partielle la valeur
de test pour le premier ministre
conservateur une circonscription rurale
dans le centre de l'angleterre pourrait
basculer aujourd'hui au profit des
libéraux démocrates boris johnson
affaibli par une série de scandales les
précisions allons de chadia edwards
statut d'international
le pire dirigeants au pire moment boris
johnson doit partir le pire premier
ministre de l'histoire du royaume uni ce
ne sont là que 3 des déclarations de
locaux si on seulement l'espace d'une
semaine
boris johnson et les conservateurs
traverse une passe difficile mais
aujourd'hui le moment est bien mal
choisi car les conservateurs s'accroche
bec et ongles aux derniers sièges de la
circonscription de new hampshire où une
élection partielle a lieu aujourd'hui
les bureaux ont ouvert et le resteront
jusqu'à ce soir
avant même le dépouillement les
libéraux-démocrates parle d'une quasi
égalité entre eux et les conservateurs
mais on sait que boris johnson se
prépare à une défaite
ce n'est bien sûr pas une grande
surprise au vu du contexte politique
des semaines et des semaines
d'accusations de corruption sans
mentionner les fêtes de noël qui aurait
eu lieu vers cette période l'année
dernière mais la cerise sur le gâteau ce
sont les 101 députés conservateurs de
l'arrière ban qui ont voté contre le
gouvernement cette semaine
il s'agissait du vote crucial sur le
pass vaccinale un événement majeur ici
101 députés ont voté contre boris
johnson et contre la consigne du whip du
parti
c'est l'une des plus importantes fronde
du mandat de boris johnson malgré tout
cela le premier ministre britannique
essaye encore de pavoiser ventes ont
notamment le programme de rappel
accélérer cette semaine
comme nous le savons bien sûr un million
de personnes doivent être vaccinées
chaque jour pour atteindre l'échéance du
gouvernement la vaccination de tous les
adultes d'ici au mois prochain
mais déjà les objectifs ne sont pas
atteints avec seulement six cent
cinquante mille personnes vaccinées en
24 heures
dans le même temps la pression est de
plus en plus forte sur boris johnson
pour qu'il en fasse plus qu'il aille
plus loin avec les restrictions qu'ovide
mais étant donné ses difficultés
actuelles avec la chambre des communes
serait ce vraiment possible
dans tous les cas aujourd'hui la
question est simple boris johnson
va-t-il perdre ce ciel de northtrop
shaikh
si oui ce serait la première fois que ce
siège bascule depuis 1983
plus important ce pourrait être le
dernier coup de grâce à ce n'est à boris
johnson
le gouvernement johnson critique
critiqué sur son accueil des réfugiés et
des migrants restent retenus dans de
très mauvaises conditions après leur
arrivée au royaume uni c'est ce que
dénonce aujourd'hui un rapport de
l'inspection des prisons un constat
accablant au moment où les traversée
illégale par la manche athènes des
records antoine ogier
au royaume uni un comité d'inspection
des prisons a visité plusieurs centres
accueillant des migrants des hommes et
des femmes qui viennent généralement de
pays en grande instabilité économique et
politique entièrement organisé par les
passeurs les voyages coûte en moyenne
près d'une dizaine de milliers d'euros
par migrants des voyages qui pour
atteindre la destination finale dure en
moyenne trois semaines et sont souvent
très dangereux vingt-sept personnes
femmes et enfants compris pour la
plupart originaires du kurdistan irakien
sont mortes lors du naufrage du 24
novembre 2021 cette année ce sont près
de 26000 migrants qui ont réussi à
rejoindre les côtes britanniques cela
représente plus de trois fois plus
d'arrivées que l'année dernière et 14
fois plus qu'en 2019 mais malgré ces
afflux de population le rapport publié
par le comité d'inspection des prisons
dénonce une prise en charge déplorable
lié à un manque de moyens en réponse au
nombre croissant des traversées de la
manche un site du ministère de la
défense va être transformée en centre de
contrôle de sécurité et d'identité sur
le territoire britannique
le ministère de l'intérieur a confirmé
qu'une partie du site du ministère de la
défense a man stone dans le kent serait
utilisé comme site d'accueil des
migrants d'ici janvier 2022 ce site
sécurisé et pourra accueillir les
migrants pendant cinq jours au maximum
le temps de procéder aux contrôles de
sécurité et d'identité en france 2000
migrants sont présentes grande synthe et
calais le gouvernement français estime
que 62 % de ceux qui traversent la
manche sont éligibles au droit d'asile
mais seulement 3% dépose une demande en
france mais alors pourquoi est ce que
les migrants cherchent tout prix
atteindre le royaume uni l'une des
raisons principales seraient la
souplesse du droit du travail vous
pouvez sur place travailler et payer des
impôts sans avoir de papiers ce qui
n'est pas le cas sur le territoire
européen
deuxièmement le risque de renvoi vers
les pays d'origine est mince car les
britanniques excluent ceux peu 6000
personnes seulement par an pour plus
d'un million d'immigrés clandestins
enfin les migrants qui se massent sur
les côtes du nord appartiennent
généralement à des communautés déjà
installé de l'autre côté de la manche et
cherche à les rejoindre depuis sept ans
2020 les baraquements militaires de la
pierre sont sous le feu des critiques
des demandeurs d'asile et des avocats
qui estiment les conditions d'accueil
sordide ce appartenant à de la détention
déguisé mais malgré un recours pénal
l'été dernier le site devrait être
utilisé au moins jusqu'à 2025
et retour au sommet des dirigeants de
l'union européenne les vingt-sept réunis
à bruxelles aujourd'hui et demain parmi
les sujets sur la table les tensions en
russie ukraine les européens veulent
éviter une escalade du conflit relancer
les négociations avec moscou un dossier
déjà évoqué hier par les dirigeants du
vieux continent et leurs homologues des
pays du partenariat hawk ride orientale
les explications de notre correspondant
antoine claireaux dans la capitale russe
ces derniers jours la présidente de la
commission européenne mais encore le
ministre français des affaires
étrangères ont eu des mots très forts
envers la russie en dépit de la menace
de conséquences stratégiques massives en
cas d'atteinte à l'intégralité du
territoire ukrainien la porte parole de
la diplomatie russe a répondu une
nouvelle fois à ces accusations en
disant que son pays n'avait nullement
l'intention est là
il s'agit d'une campagne lancée
délibérément de fausses informations de
désinformation qui vise à créer d'une
part une image de la russie en tant
qu'agresseur et d'autre part
probablement à créer des tensions
supplémentaires dans la région de la mer
noire de l'ukraine de la frontière russo
ukrainienne dans la situation dans le
sud est de l'ukraine et tout cela
n'apportera pas d'éléments de stabilité
et de sécurité tant dans les relations
internationales en général que dans
l'agenda régional
bladier poutine a plusieurs fois pris la
parole ces derniers jours pour évoquer
le dossier ukrainien et pour justifier
la présence de troupes russes à sa
frontière à la suite et ses différentes
interventions maria sharapova a tenu a
résumé la position de la russie sur ce
sujet
sur la base de certaines données
ouvertes et secrètes les représentants
du gouvernement allemand ont établi que
l'armée russe était situé sur le
territoire de la russie eh bien je les
félicite pour cette découverte oui il y
a une armée russe sur le territoire de
la fédération de russie quand un état
dispose de ses forces armées qui se
trouvent sur son territoire il a le
droit de mener des exercices de
redéployer ses forces qui plus est de
mettre en oeuvre la réforme des forces
armées ou je ne sais pas d'effectuer des
manoeuvres sur son propre territoire
nous faisons ce sur notre territoire
nous en avons le droit
patiemment les autorités russes que ce
soit le kremlin ou le ministère des
affaires étrangères explique à qui veut
l'entendre que la russie n'a aucune
velléité offensive et qu'elle cherche
simplement assurer la sécurité de son
territoire et c'est d'ailleurs avec cet
objectif en tête que moscou cherche à
ouvrir au plus vite des négociations
avec l'alliance atlantique
et direction présent les états unis où
l'assassinât en 1963 de john fitzgerald
kennedy refait la une des journaux les
archives nationales américaines ont
publié hier pas moins de 1500 documents
en lien avec la mort du 35e président
des états unis alors que contiennent ces
écrits on en parle tout de suite avec
notre correspondante au m'abonner à
washington bonsoir thomas enquêtes
policières écrits intimes ou encore
discussions privées apparence et
documents sensibles ou ont bel et bien
raviver la flamme des les passionnés de
jeff kate sont très nombreux
oui il y avait beaucoup d'attentes parce
qu'il ya encore beaucoup
d'interrogations sur les circonstances
exactes de la mort de john fitzgerald
kennedy mais je me dois de vous dire
qu'il ya maintenant de la déception
parce qu'il n'y a pas véritablement de
révélations fracassantes dans ces
documents qui ont été publiés cette
semaine alors évidemment l'intégralité
de ces documents a pas encore été
analysés ce qu'on peut dire c'est qu'il
s'agit essentiellement de fichiers issus
de la cia lors il ya un des spécialistes
aux états unis de ce dossier jeff keay
qui se bat d'ailleurs depuis des années
pour la publication intégrale de ces
documents qui s'est déjà penché sur
cette publication lui non plus estime
qu'il n'y a pas de grandes révélations
dans ses fichiers en fait pour lui le
plus notable c'est le fait que ces
données soient désormais numérisés ce
qui va faciliter à l'avenir le travail
des chercheurs et puis surtout il
insiste sur le fait qu'il ya des
éléments qui n'ont toujours pas été
publiés comme par exemple une interview
de la veuve du frère john fitzgerald
kennedy écouter
ni jaqee ni robert kennedy ne croyait à
la théorie officielle selon laquelle
kennedy aurait été tué par un homme seul
sans raison ils disaient en privé que
jfk avait été tué par ses ennemis de
l'intérieur s'est su qu'il y assurent
ces enregistrements et c'est pourquoi
ils sont si sensibles cette version
officielle évidemment remise en cause
depuis des années la thèse donc de
l'assassinât par un homme seul lit h
oswald et plus généralement l'anc est
menée par la commission warren sont
souvent remises en question comme
c'était déjà le cas dans le film paru en
1991 par le réalisateur oliver stone
c'est pourquoi beaucoup de voix
demandent que tous les documents soient
déclassifiées il faut savoir qu'aux
états unis une loi datant de 1992 impose
la déclassification de ces documents
dans un délai de 25 ans ce qui nous a
menés à octobre 2017 mais depuis entre
temps est des délais supplémentaires ont
été accordés officiellement pour des
raisons de protection de la sécurité
nationale américaine alors donald trump
puis joe biden ont donc autorisé la
publication de certains documents mais
beaucoup d'entre eux sont en fait encore
gardé secret et puis surtout beaucoup de
ces fichiers sont caviardés par souci de
confidentialité ce qui les rend
illisibles pour le grand public il faut
comprendre qu'il ya une forte demande
aux états unis pour connaître toutes les
circonstances autour du décès du 35e
président américain qui a donc été
assassiné le 22 novembre 1963
ça fait bientôt 60 ans c'est vrai qu'on
reste un petit peu sur notre faim sur
ses 1500 pages thomas merci en tout cas
pour ces précisions en direct de
washington
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
à l'interview télé d'emmanuel micro hier
soir qui n'aurait ni convaincu ni
mobiliser des français c'est la
conclusion d'un sondage réalisé ce soir
pour le figaro six français sur dix est
signe que le président français a été
mauvais alors l'interview d'emmanuel
macron at-elle fait un flop on attend
vos réactions sur notre compte
télégramme
[Musique]
chacun prétend détenir la vérité trop
souvent il ne s'agit que de spéculations
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose
une convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash nous vous parlerons de
tout sans langue de bois
un
[Musique]
des freins à priori du nucléaire c'est
l'émergence dé nouvelles sources
d'énergie aujourd'hui nous sommes le
pays qui produit l'électricité la plus
décarbonés au monde on peut rêver à
couvrir de toute la planète de
d'éoliennes mais quand ça produit un
tiers du temps que fait-on pour le reste
à puis il ya aussi la démographie en
sont toujours à l'afrique quand même
avec un milliard d'habitants plus la
surface de l'afrique ne soit pas
suffisante pour mettre des panneaux
solaires ou sinon ça se fera au
détriment de l'agriculture on joue aux
apprentis sorciers y compris au niveau
européen quand un pays comme l'allemagne
décide du lourd lama d'arrêter le
nucléaire trouvera les centrales à
charbon l'allemagne est le plus gros
pollueurs européens aujourd'hui le djia
qui a sonné l'alarmé sur les risques de
du réchauffement climatique dit bien que
les besoins en électricité sont
considérables d'ici 2050 il faudra 50 %
de production électrique en plus comment
va-t-on faire
[Musique]
depuis plus d'un an
le président macron était convaincu que
le retrait annonce la chancelière
allemande le positionnerait comme le
chef naturel d'une europe à laquelle ils
imposeraient s'est vu la réalité
allemande est venue frapper ce plan de
plein fouet ces olaf schulze ministre
des finances et chef du parti
social-démocrate située à gauche qui a
gagné les élections on est loin de
l'autonomie stratégique européenne
défendue par notre président pour une
europe qui protège l'allemagne a pris
conscience et assument de plus en plus
ouvertement quelle est la puissance
centrale en europe le programme commun
qu'il s'apprête à mettre en oeuvre ne va
pas dans le sens des intérêts français
[Musique]
chaque jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs sont joués mais les
règles ne sont pas toujours respectées
les couleurs changent de camp
les pions prennent la place des rois
de fine stratégie peuvent porter des
résultats inattendus
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire
je suis allée de chômeurs et chaque
semaine dans l'échiquier mondial nous
analyserons les coups les plus complexes
du jeu politique internationale
à bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collective vous le
savez pour moi qui dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative en sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez déçu livrant une
forme c'est quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï pg les jeunes
c'était des valeurs de droite c'était
des gens qui travaillent c'est des gens
qui avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose à leurs enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soient pas publics
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct il y a quand
même la liberté je vous remercie de
m'avoir invité
[Musique]
la situation politique d'abord c'est
quoi votre analyse de cette espèce de
tsunami les choses commencent à
s'organiser plus entre deux poules ou
trois peut-être la france elle est entre
la droite et l'extrême droite on peut
pas éviter ce constat la situation
politique va se passer à droite et sur
des thématiques de droite ça veut dire
par exemple que votre candidate à être
obligé de durcir ses positions de droite
l'idée de ces primaires internes c'était
de créer à l'arrivée l'équipe de france
et l'équipe de france elle est là c'est
la première fois première fois dans
l'histoire de france qu'une femme selon
les sondages peut être élue présidente
de la république c'est sans doute une
révolution qui permet de dire que le
plafond de verre a peut être enfin
exploser
[Musique]
il est 21h merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième partie d'émission au
sommaire président des riches hors sol
un moulin à paroles égocentré
l'opposition à gauche comme à droite ne
mâche pas ses mots dans l'interview
fleuve emmanuel macron un exercice qui
n'aurait ni convaincu ni mobiliser des
français selon un sondage réalisé ce
soir pour le figaro alors l'interview du
président at-elle fait un flop on attend
votre avis sur le comté d g d'herbe des
france de débat est ouvert
[Musique]
la longue interview d'emmanuel mettront
diffuser la télévision ne semble pas
avoir marqué les français c'est le
résultat d'un sondage publié ce soir par
le figaro six personnes interrogées sur
dix estiment que président était mauvais
une interview avec des airs prononcé de
campagne électorale qui n'a pas manqué
en tout cas d'agacer l'opposition
sébastien zaba
pendant près de deux heures le président
de la république a établi un constat de
son quinquennat sécurité crise sanitaire
économie et quand il évoque ses projets
pour 2022 le président manque de vendre
la mèche
jamais pensé qu'on pouvait en cinq ans
tout faire on transforme pas un pays en
cinq ans et donc je continue à me
projeter et j'essaie d'avoir l'esprit de
sérieux et donc quand vous me demandez
qu'est ce que vous avez fait je vous
réponds en effet résultats concrets mais
j'essaie de garder de la vision pour
satisfaire monsieur rouge bas et de dire
je projette le pays à 10 ans et je n'ai
cessé de dire aux buts que nous sommes
vers on doit les uns président aux airs
de candidats mais un candidat absents
éloigner des français parmi ses
détracteurs nombreux ont pointé cette
absence sur la scène électorale dont le
candidat du groupe la france insoumise
jean luc mélenchon en déplacement en
guadeloupe un moulin à paroles égocentré
tiède et sans souffle sans un mot sur la
catastrophe en cours en outre-mer sans
un mot sérieux sur les crises
écologiques et sociales ni la paix dans
le monde ni la guerre du mali bavardage
hors sol même son de cloche du côté de
marine le pen la candidate du
rassemblement national était quant à
elle à la rencontre des électeurs
mahorais pour dénoncer l'insécurité et
le délaissement de lille moi ma vocation
c'est d'être présidente de la république
française est donc ce qui m'importe
c'est la situation économique de mayotte
or aujourd'hui je m'aperçois de la
situation économique de mayotte est
obéré notamment par le comportement de
du président des comores en matière
migratoire pas un département en
métropole ne supporterai de vivre ce que
je vis mayotte voilà c'est le résumé
c'est cela et donc il faut en même temps
leur apporter soutien et l'affection
mais pas seulement il faut vraiment leur
apporter je veux dire une politique
maintenant qu'ils soient une politique
d'une très grande fermeté pour donner un
avenir aux jeunes de mayotte parce que
c'est eux dont l'avenir est obéré en
plus de cette absence la classe
politique est monté au créneau auprès du
conseil supérieur de l'audiovisuel pour
signaler ce qu'ils considèrent comme du
temps de parole alors que le président
ne s'est toujours pas déclaré
officiellement candidat et les critiques
donc avant de constater sont donc
nombreuses de la part de l'opposition
mais aussi des français en 24 heures
après l'émission du président de la
république alors emmanuel macron sur tf1
un flop c'est l'objet de notre
décryptage
[Musique]
avec nous pour en parler sur ce plateau
thierry paul valette gilet jaune vous
est aussi le fondateur du comité stopp
zemmour 2022 bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous à vos côtés david xavier weiss
maire-adjoint et l'air de
levallois-perret soutien de valérie
pécresse bonsoir et merci également
d'être là pour vous accompagner en
liaison par skype cette fois-ci sergio
coronado conseiller en communication
politique ancien député europe ecologie
les verts arthur paris c'est également
par parole du parti la reconquête en
partie de d'eric zemmour merci à tous
les deux aussi d'être là on va
s'intéresser fils c'est ce qui est plus
frais à ce sondage est tombé ce soir un
sondage au doxa bakbone consulting
réalisée pour le figaro
eh bien regardez ils sont seulement 9%
avoir suivi cette interview en anglais 9
% des interrogés 16% à l'avoir vu en
partie seuls 37% des français ont trouvé
le locataire de l'élysée convaincant
alors c'est il faut le préciser le plus
bas niveau enregistré sur toutes les
interventions des manuels macro depuis
le début de la crise sanitaire enfin ça
c'est un petit peu dur ski français sur
dix estiment que ce dernier a tout
simplement été mauvais serge coronado
vous qui êtes aussi communicants comment
vous expliquer ces mauvais résultats si
j'ose dire parce que forcément il avait
l'oeil dessus emmanuel macron sur ces
sondages de postes une interview c'est
l'exercice chez lui bref ça n'a pas plu
sauf que la politique c'est jamais qu'un
exercice de communication c'est bien
autre chose et le problème des manuels
d'un cros et son bilan son passif en
fait donc monde il se présente devant
les français en disant qu'il a changé
les français ont-ils tous l'impression
en fait de voir un retour aux jeunes
livrés non après vous papy fait de la
résistance
et cette fameuse chanson qui n'a pas
pété non je n'ai pas changé en fait les
gens voient bien réside ont déconnecté
de la réalité sociale du pays
un président qui a beaucoup fait en
faveur des catégories les plus aisées
que malmenés les catégories populaires
on se souvient la manière extrêmement
violente dont le moment des gels et j'en
ai été traités on se souvient également
de sa politique à l'égard de la jeunesse
avec la réforme de zabel début pour
l'écologiste que je suis c'est quand
même extrêmement choquant c'est c'est
tout à fait même surprenant pour
quelques années sa génération pas un mot
sur l'écologie pas un mot en fait sur
les crises que nous affronterons
aujourd'hui à la fois la crise sanitaire
et la crise et la crise écologique avec
l'effondrement du vivant la crise
climatique est donc cet exercice cela ne
peut pas se résumer pour un candidat en
campagne
quand on est président de la république
en activité à un exercice de
communication d'inspiration très nord
américaine en fait on vient devant des
journalistes sans véritable
contradicteur en face de soi faire
amende honorable faire son mea culpa les
français ça si qu'ils ont vécu sous le
quinquennat d'emmanuel mac ce qu'on ait
quatre ans va donner dans la parole
pardonnez-moi sage coronado en tout cas
c'était pour la première impression
david xavier weiss c'est quoi c'est un
exercice qu'on a peut-être trop vu où
c'est vraiment lié comme semble penser
sergio coronado là à la personnalité et
au bilan des manuels mac os que même
giscard qui était à l'époque un
président en avance sur son temps
n'aurait pas fait aussi aussi dépassé
aussi suranné comme exercice on est
passé d'un mac faye et karito et de
youtube eur 1,8 à l'elysée le 14 juillet
à deux heures d'exercices est pas la
même cible non mais deux heures
d'exercices oui parle que de lui et en
plus il parle de lui en essayant de dire
j'ai changé mais en montrant que c'est
un président complètement déconnecté il
ne savait pas que des français étaient à
10 euros la fin du mois il ne savait pas
qu'il y avait des français des jeunes
enfants qui ne mangeaient pas forcément
à leur fin en france un français qui
nous impressionne avec mais qui ne
connaît pas les français il a fallu
qu'il aille sur le terrain rencontrer
des maires qu'ils ont expliqué la
réalité du terrain moi j'en pars il
avait dit soyez fiers d'être des
amateurs on est on a vu ce que ça a
donné à l'assemblée nationale et on voit
ce que ça donnait finalement à l'elysée
de l'amateurisme mais je ne suis pas sûr
que ce qu'on attend pour la fonction
suprême ce soit cet amateurisme qui soit
sacralisé on attend que quelqu'un qui
prenne de la hauteur il pas pris on
attend quelqu'un qui fasse un vrai mea
culpa il n'a pas fait bon c'est pas
parce qu'il a dit hier je me suis je
m'excuse j'ai froissé des gens ont dit
en les traitant deux ans les 30 ans nul
quand effectivement j'étais face à ceux
qui sont riches et ceux qui qui créent
de la richesse je vous ai traité de gens
qui ne valait rien oui ça c'était de
toute façon c'était une insulte mais
elle reste on sait très bien qu'il est
c'est un fou mais culpa lors des
audiences assez moyenne parce que c'est
quand même la première chaîne en france
nos confrères de tf1 emmanuel macron
donc le 15 sur tf 1 3 million 800 mille
téléspectateurs eric zemmour le
30/11 2021 sur tf1 plus de 6 millions
500 mille téléspectateurs une interview
avec gilles bouleau c'est donc deux fois
moins que votre poulain arthur paris ça
doit vous faire plaisir comment vous
vous l'expliquer c'est l'attrait de la
nouveauté contre quelque chose qu'on a
peut-être déjà vu et revu
écoutez je crois que les chiffres
parlent d'eux mêmes comme vous l'avez
dit voit que les audiences suivent eric
zemmour quel que soit le média sur
lequel il s'exprime également lui n'est
pas neuf dans l'univers médiatique
puisque c'était un journaliste et
chroniqueur avant d'être candidat à la
présidentielle donc c'est pas
nécessairement
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas nécessairement l'attrait de la
nouveauté qui justifie je pense là la
réputation en tout cas le le fait
qu'eric zemmour aujourd'hui il suffit de
manière massive c'est surtout parce
qu'ils s'emparent des thématiques qui
concerne que les français emmanuel
macron on voit la fin de son quinquennat
a été le président du grand déclassement
parce que aujourd'hui un point de vue
économique sur l'explosion de la dette
sur la balance commerciale extrêmement
déficitaire les gilet jaune qui ont
animé ce quinquennat et qui était un
révélateur du malaise qui né en france
lui aujourd'hui eric zemmour il a cette
capacité à parler aux français les
français écoutent les français le
suivent les français sont attentifs à
rappeler que le mouvement le parti
reconquête qui l'a lancé leur à
villepinte de 5 décembre il ya déjà plus
de 70 mille adhérents ce sont des
adhérents fiable puisque des battures
eric zemmour s'était sur emmanuel macron
pardonnez moi non mais voilà je vous ai
posé la question sur cette poule part
d'audience et pourquoi emmanuel macron
avait fait moins auront sera en fera
certainement ce débat une autre fois
mais pas mandé gilet jaune parce que
c'est vrai que
oui des paroles pardonnez moi un petit
mot
beaucoup plus d'audience et en effet la
trilane beauté joue considéré pendant
cet exercice
mais rappelez-vous aussi les
commentaires après cette entrée en
campagne sur tf1 les
commentaires étaient plutôt négatif
contre la personne c'est ce qui a valu
même ajouté à un débat sur eric zemmour
on va parler s'ordonner mois sachant et
dont on va parler des jd jaune parce que
mène le micro et a été longuement
interrogé dessus ça a été évidemment une
étape de son quinquennat que retient-il
de cet épisode vous propose de l'écouter
la crise des gilet jaune juste pour
peut-être revenir d'un mot sur elle
elle dit quoi elle dit des peurs
profondes qu'il ya dans notre société et
au delà des violences dont on a parlé de
ce que j'évoquais elle
c'est à mes yeux le moment où les
françaises et les français
en particulier celles et ceux qui
travaillent parce que beaucoup des
filets jaunes ont un travail mais sont
mal payés c'est cette france qui se sont
invisibles et elle va sur les
ronds-points et elle m'aide et gilet
jaune cette france parce qu'elle dit
vous ne reconnaissez pas
et ça on peut pas le nier sa les paul
valette il a compris les gilet jaune
je suis complètement abasourdi parce que
il n'a pas quelques mots à dire par
rapport au gilet jaune il a simplement
un mot à dire gilet jaune et gilet jaune
on peur seulement il faut pas oublier
qu'on a fait peur aux jets des jaunes
sur le terrain avec les notamment
violences policières ce qui est terrible
c'est que phil ty ar pardonnez moi mais
il dit la violence a été légitime
certains ont légitimé la violence ont
fait allusion à l'arc de triomphe
notamment puy-en-velay ont parlé de
cette violence ça vous a choqué ou aussi
qu'il est retenu que ça et pas forcément
les violences sur le terrain oui bien
sûr je suis un petit peu un petit peu
dommage mais c'est un président qui
stigmatisent ans concernant l'épisode
sur les champs elysées à mon association
d g des jo de citoyens avaient averti
monsieur castaner qu'il y aurait à cette
période là des black blocs qui
investirait des champs elysées pour les
saccages et quelle réponse a été
apportée 20 crs aux alentours des de
l'arc de triomphe donc on a laissé faire
on encourager cette violence maintenant
vous savez emmanuel macron s'adresser
aux français en disant je commence à
aimer les français oui il ne les aime
pas il commence à peine à d aimer c'est
ça qui est dramatique maintenant vous
savez quand on regarde les chiffres mais
a peut-être éventuellement réputée à
très grands pas les aimer sa lutte âpre
éventuellement les aimez mais vous savez
moi finalement son intervention hier
soir et les chiffres sont là les
français ne sont pas dupes sa parole
n'est plus entendue et les désavouer il
a mis à mal la fonction présidentielle
et puis c'était quoi finalement c'était
un mea culpa de croque-mort qu'il a fait
hier emmanuel macron tourner autour de
sa propre personne non c'est non
miscibles c'est intolérable il faut pas
s'étonner que maintenant lié une part
belle pour les extrêmes dont la personne
d'eric zemmour mais ce qui est étonnant
exercice c'est qu'effectivement on a un
président de la république qui se
comporte comme un commentateur de la vie
politique hier il commentait finalement
l'activité des gilets jaunes et on a un
commentateur de la vie politique
télévisé moquez de qui veut devenir
président de la république on a quand
même une inversion des valeurs
aujourd'hui une inversion des valeurs ce
chassé croisé qui est assez étonnant et
qui consterne finalement beaucoup de
téléspectateurs alors je me suis même
spa eric zemmour mais reese et moi a
toujours été un commentateur de la vie
politique et là on al'impression de la
rêverie de la république qui finalement
se rend compte de ce qu'est la france de
ce que sont les français de ce que
ressentent les français
c'est ça qui est dramatique ne nous
auront pas quand il n'a pas tiré les
leçons et les conséquences de ce qui
s'est passé de la crise et j'ai des
jaunes la plus âgée des jaunes force est
de constater qu'aucune réponse n'a été
réellement apporter voilà et de
l'intervention du président emmanuel
macron finalement c'est une intervention
qui est centré sur lui même il est son
propre conseiller il se met en scène
lui-même il est narcissique de liesse
qui dit quand il parle toujours des dd
gilet jaune et cette petite phrase qu'on
a relevé écouter
quelque chose s'est passé un moment qui
fait que la foule laquelle parfois
c'était hugo trahi le peuple la foule
devient folle il ya eu de la violence
extrême dans nos rues dans la société
pendant beaucoup de samedi à eu de la
violence qui a d'ailleurs touché
beaucoup de nos compatriotes des
commerçants il ya eu de la violence
aussi il ya des manifestants qui ont eu
je le sais à subir aussi beaucoup de
choses parce qu'ils se sont parfois
exposés certains ont été violents
eux-mêmes donc cette période a été une
période très dure la deuxième chose à la
crise je crois profondément c'est que
toutes les paroles ne se valent pas on
peut souffrir on peut avoir une parole
d'h on peut avoir un avis sur l'épidémie
mais de la crise des îles et jaune à
l'épidémie nous avons en quelque sorte
créé un système on pense que toutes les
paroles se valent c'est pas vrai il ya
des gens qui sont démocratiquement élu
par le peuple pour porter sa voix un
député de la république n'est pas
l'équivalent d'un manifestant quand il
s'agit de parler de la nation parce
qu'il a une légitimité démocratique
sergio coronado c'était cette deuxième
partie d'intervention qui m'intéressait
ça veut dire quoi c'est une façon de
remettre les manifestants à leur place
là bas on n'a pas la même c'est d'abord
de romarin d'abord il ya une conception
un peu surprenante de la démocratie qui
consisterait finalement a confié les
rênes du pays yves tous les seynois
à personnel politique député président
compris son qu'ils aient jamais de
comptes à rendre rappelons-nous le
mépris affiché par emmanuel macron des
corps intermédiaires du parlement
lui-même en fait de sa majorité je crois
que c'est une conception surannée les
gens ont envie des citoyens entendent y
est aujourd'hui de participer à
l'élaboration de la décision politique
de donner leur point de vue d'exister
comme citoyen sur la scène publique et
puisqu'il est assez choquant est
tellement c'est cette façon très
psychologisante en fait de parler des
gilet jaune et gilet jaune ils ont mis
en lumière une réalité qui est celle de
notre pays inégalités profondes
inégalités territoriales
une partie de la population
effectivement qui travaillent et qui le
15 du mois a très peu d'argent pour
finir ce mois là en fait des gens qui se
sont soulevés contre une politique qui
se voulait écologistes en fait avec
l'augmentation du prix des carburants
mais ils y visaient à freiner à
compenser les cadeaux fiscaux qui avait
été fait aux plus riches en début du
quinquennat donc cette manière de parler
de ce mouvement social d'une ampleur
sans précédent dans l'histoire politique
française n'avait pas vu ça depuis
presque un siècle en fait en france
comme d'une foule compacte qui devient
folle toujours ses arguments et ses mots
qui blessent qui stigmatise et puis je
note également les l'absence d'empathie
il ya eu des violences il ya eu des
personnes qui ont perdu la vie il ya eu
également des personnes éborgné jamais
emmanuel macron nattier ce maire ou pas
avec l'utilisation extrêmement brutal de
la force des pouvoirs de police qui me
sont confiées par le peuple français je
trouve qu'on est fait il confirme cette
déconnexion de la fonction payant ciel
et de la réalité du pays est normalement
appelées à conduire arthur paris je vois
vous inquiétez vous êtes d'accord avec
sergio coronado on vous attendait pas
forcément sur la même ligne mais soit
oui
oui je suis d'accord il ya dix 10
précédemment moi ce qui m'a choqué hier
c'est cette phrase d'emmanuel macron jeu
les notaires j'ai appris à mieux aimer
les français vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure cette phrase est hallucinante il
faut que emmanuel macron au bout de cinq
ans finissent par commencé après
c'est un homme hors sol diplômé de l'ena
il a enchaîné brillamment une carrière
en tant qu'associé cherokee depuis
secrétaire général ministre donc si oui
c'est un homme qui n'a jamais vécu comme
comme les français comme comme moi comme
vous il a jamais pris le bus le métro
dont qui sait pas ce que c'est d'avoir
des difficultés pour finir le mois c'est
parce que c'est se sentir agressés dans
les transports en commun donc moi ce qui
me ce qui me gêne profondément au dans
le bilan des manuels macro hier c'était
son autosatisfaction et sa sa
déconnexion totale et que le quotidien
des français effectivement quand il
parle des gilet jaune il ne parle que
des violences mais les gilet jaune ce
n'était pas juste des violences c'était
une crise profonde mais tonalité à 10h
et des comprimés j'étais absente
invisible c'est un ballet on a vu qu'ils
avaient eux est clos juste après cette
hausse de la taxe carbone les 80
kilomètres heure donc c'est à dire que
vous avez le pouvoir blanc au parisien
mac rognant déconnecté déconnecté de la
réalité des français c'est ça qui a
produit les gilet jaune donc emmanuel
macro n'a toujours pas compris il a
l'impression que les jeunes c'est lui
est tombé dessus par hasard parce qu'il
a pas eu de chance non c'était une
réaction au mépris et la condescendance
qui sont vraiment des qui sont
inhérentes à sa personnalité
oui
une terrible erreur qui est fait et je
les ai entendus encore dans la bouche de
monsieur séquelles qu'on parle des gilet
jaune au passé selon les gilets jaunes
sont toujours présents sur les
ronds-points et notamment tous les
samedis on ne les voit pas on ne les
entend pas ils n'ont plus eu un écho
médiatique tels qu'ils lui il y a deux
ans il ya trois ans mais ils sont
toujours là et ce qui s'est passé il ya
deux ans peut revenir ça c'est la
première chose est la problématique
c'est que aujourd'hui les il n'y a pas
que monsieur mâcon qui n'aiment pas les
français les politiques n'aiment plus
les français ils aiment leurs électeurs
et ça se limite à ça et quand on parle
de deux présidents qui est déconnecté
oui ils le sont tous monsieur zemmour
est déconnecté on l'a vu dans ces propos
notamment par rapport
à la réponse sur le logement des gens
entre autres c'est ça la réalité il faut
déconnecter aussi puisqu'on va lancer
soutien est fou alors valérie pécresse
elle n'est pas déconnecté elle est en
train de se reconnecter maintenant dans
sa campagne et là ce sera l'occasion
aussi de devoirs et d'en discuter
comment elle va se situer par rapport à
l'elysée moore maintenant elle va se
situer aussi par après manuel macro et
quelles idées humanistes de gauche pour
est elle aussi s'approprier alors au mur
en salle et droite essaie de la question
justement droite denis grenier vice que
j'allais vous poser parce que quand on
entend et mène un emmanuel macron comme
ça être un petit peu accusés finalement
d'être hors sol on se demande comment la
candidate de droite va se positionner
simplement tout simplement en étant en
prise avec les réalités du terrain et
valérie pécresse et président de la
région ile de france depuis plus de 5
ans 6 ans elle est en charge du
quotidien des franciliens quand tu la
crise sanitaire c'est valérie pécresse
la première des présidents de région à
avoir à porter des masques
là où il n'y en avait pas et là où
l'état ne me disait surtout ne mettez
pas il surtout il n'y en a pas valérie
pécresse était aussi celle qui au
quotidien gère tous les transports 50%
des réseaux ferrés sont en ile-de-france
métros trains rer et voies ferrées de la
fff 50% sont gérés par donc ses petits
carnets
maintenant il se résume pas à l'île de
france nous avons fait aussi la la la
france et c'est l'agriculture ce sont
les termes elie le font savoir
c'est 50 % de terres agricoles c'est
aussi parce qu'on oublie on pense que le
français ou des photos ou des barres hlm
ou des départs les mêlées mais parlez
lui directement à partie par deux fois
puis simplement le représentant de
l'ailé les crises ne prenait pas souvent
les transports ou de france à
ernée
herbert s'est il des dessertes notamment
intervent lieu je ne crois pas que le
bilan d'alerté qu'est-ce qui permettent
aujourd'hui d'avoir aussi fière allure
ce plateau monsieur jay moi j'ai mon
pass navigo sur moi il est resté en rade
est resté maintenant traite je je je
peux vous dire je prends les transports
et franchement il ya une amélioration
après on peut toujours avoir autour dé
discuter des des métros qui arrivent en
retard mais je pense pas que ce soit le
le le le sujet une élection aussi
sérieuse que celle qu'est georges bush
s'est présenté dans quatre mois où on a
eu en france
on a une on a une frange non non on a un
des sujets bien plus importants que que
les problèmes du rer b je pense et qui
concerne aussi et y compris la province
on a besoin de 3000 milliards d'euros de
dette voilà mon bilan annuel matheron
3000 milliards d'euros de dettes et la
dette d'aujourd'hui ce sera l'objet de
demandes
de brevets on va vous me donner la bonne
transition parce qu'on va terminer sur
ce point parce qu'il ya eu un petit pic
décoché à votre candidate je vous
propose d'écouter emmanuel macron qui a
répondu aux critiques à peine voilées de
valérie précresse king accuse de en gros
de cramer la caisse
la situation de la dette en france et
une situation qui impose de la vigilance
maintenant il ya deux façons les trois
façons de l'aborder une façon qui
consiste à dire après moi le déluge
génération égoïste laissons la dette à
nos enfants ils se débrouilleront où
nous allons répudié cette dette les gens
qui nous ont donné l'argent ne le
reverront jamais je ne crois pas à cette
formule parce que je pense que si c'est
le message qu'on envoie il est
irresponsable c'est à dire que nos
enfants auront à la payer mais surtout
les gens ne vous font plus confiance et
au fait ça parce qu'il vous prêteront
plus d'argent donc
je ne recommande pas cette option il ya
une deuxième option qui est l'option gré
père fouettard faut couper tout de suite
c'est ce qu'on a fait depuis vingt ans à
ma droite en fait son thème maintenant
la droite arrive en disant pas de paul
était en disant cramer la caisse en dix
ans elle revient avec le rigorisme
budgétaire en disant avec sion le prix
n'a jamais marché c'est à dire ceux qui
ont fait ça ont ensuite augmenté les
impôts comme jamais bon il n'a pas admis
qu'ils s'adressent à valérie pécresse
mais quand même un journaliste voilà
notre confère la soulever votre réponse
ce monsieur m'a conquis était le le
ministre de l'économie de 2 françois
hollande ne peut pas donner des leçons
il a quand même créer 3000 milliards
d'euros de dettes et je ne sais pas et
d'ailleurs il ya il n'ya pas donner de
leçon nous en tout cas de deux pistes de
solution trois mille milliards d'euros
de dettes d'aujourd'hui c'est les impôts
de demain fatalement soit c'est des
impôts soient cédés ray services publics
en moins et on a vu ce que c'était des
services publics en moins c'est
justement des territoires ruraux qui
seront abandonnés et aujourd'hui on en
paie le prix on en a payé le prix avec
la crise et gilet jaune la crise et les
jaunes c'est quoi ces trente ans
d'abandon des territoires ruraux idée
des zones périurbaines c'est important
de le dire mais non mais c'est le ton
corps est devant nous le dira et ça ils
la même taille le l'audace ou en tout
cas le courage de le reconnaître hier ça
prouve encore une fois qu'il n'est pas
il ne connais pas ni les français ni la
france est l'amie ni les français ni la
france et c'est bien dommage pour un
live by km dames en quatre ans presque
cinq ans pour apprendre à connaître et
aimer les français et aujourd'hui on se
rend compte de quoi que tu as ta mère
phare du tout ça n'a servi à rien ça a
servi à rien fait dernier tour de table
sergio coronado oui dans un débat
politique faut parler des déclarations
et des engagements concrets
nous dise où on a supprimé les 150000
pose de fonctionner que valérie pécresse
annonce il est élu président de la
république est-ce que c'est dans les
hôpitaux est-ce que c'est dans les
écoles est-ce que c'est dans d'autres
services publics ce serait un événement
en tout cas l'objet le croyez moi dans
certains venus déballer je vous
inviterai volontiers fait beaucoup moins
peur qu eric zemmour bon eh eh bah alors
voilà le mot de la fin pour vous arthur
paris elle fait moins peur que enfin
tout le monde fait moins peur
manifestement qu'eric zemmour c'est ce
qui semble être partagée sur sur ce
plateau et vous avez le mot de la fin
profitez-en je vous remercie écoutez moi
j'écoute le porte parole de valérie
pécresse c'est bien j'entends que c'est
une bonne gestionnaire c'est une
gestionnaire donc moi je pense ça le
fera une excellente ministre d'emmanuel
macron pourquoi pas sa première ministre
ce sera une femme en plus donc ça
pourrait être un clin d'oeil important
pour pour mac ont maintenant eux hier il
faut souligner qu emmanuel macron a
beaucoup visé eric zemmour dans ses
phrases dans des sous-entendus et à
juste titre pourquoi parce que
aujourd'hui eric zemmour il porte un
projet de civilisation il porte un
projet pour la france et donc emmanuel
macron a bien compris que l'adversaire
de son corps parce qu'eux mêmes à
coincer le grand libéral legrand un
mondialiste legrand individus hors sol
et que voilà le représentant aujourd'hui
de la souveraineté de la souveraineté
populaire cette france patriotes et de
cette france a enraciné si eric zemmour
est donc valérie pécresse encore une
fois je pense qu'elle ferait une
excellente ministre du budget des
manuels macro mais je pense qu'elle
devrait candide était pour eux pour 2022
visiblement tout le monde est d'accord
sur le plateau pour dire qu' il n'y a
pas beaucoup de différences entre macro
et de crise on va quand même et donner
le mot de la fin pour la réponse ça
serait page et oui vous savez monsieur
zemmour monsieur zemmour lui veut 4
c'est une civilisation
il prend en otage l'élection
présidentielle pour ce faire et ça c'est
dramatique et ça c'est terrible là est
la vraie différence sincèrement qu'on
soit de droite qu'on soit de gauche
contre des extrêmes la seule candidate à
pouvoir battre emmanuel macron et si on
veut une vraie alternance à les
prochaines c'est valérie pécresse donc
moi je vous invite tous si vous avez une
vraie alternance à rejoindre la liga qui
est presque vous que ce soit 4
semble-t-il emmanuel lacroix bel et bien
lancé la campagne 1 depuis hier soir
merci à tous les quatre en tout cas
d'avoir été avec nous et c'est la fin de
cette émission rendez-vous et
le 27 puisque ya zem prend une semaine
de congés de fin d'année portez vous
bien d'ici là et puis évidemment
l'actualité qui continue toujours sur rt
france
[Musique]
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions du procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde finalement
été formés de gens merveilleux et
d'aider des gens ignoble en fait vous ne
savez pas comment votre fils est mort
vous devez enquêter sur tout et vous
confronter ils étaient ni sur la liste
des morts ni sur la bbc une juriste et
hopitalisé il était nulle part est ce
qu'on peut vivre malgré cette douleur
quand j'ai écrit à la fois je souffrais
parce que ça me rappelait des beaux
souvenirs avec stéphane en même temps
c'était très douloureux et puis
aujourd'hui je me suis aperçu que ça
permettait d'extraire de de moi même
toute cette histoire est donc ça m'a
apporté un peu de recul un peu
d'apaisement mais la douleur et la
colère seront là jusqu'à ma mort
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]